[Música]
quedan unas horas para conocer al
próximo campeón del mundo de fútbol
Francia y Argentina se enfrentan en un
duelo en que kilian mbappé y Lionel
Messi son los principales protagonistas
sigue la tensión política y social en
Perú la presidenta Dina boluarte pidió
al congreso que apruebe su adelanto
electoral para diciembre de 2023 en las
calles siguen entre tanto las protestas
contra la encarcelación de Pedro
Castillo que dejan Ya al menos 20
muertos
el tabaco es la principal causa de
cáncer de pulmón en el mundo según la
Organización Mundial de la Salud en
Bolivia sin embargo un estudio señala a
la contaminación del aire como causa
primera de este tipo de afección
Bienvenidos a Nuevo informativo de
France 24 dedicado a las principales
noticias del continente americano y al
Mundial de fútbol de Qatar 2022 Mi
nombre es Rodrigo sedano y es un gusto
acompañarlos abrimos este informativo
precisamente con el mundial de Qatar
este domingo se la tan esperada final
entre Francia y Argentina la albiceleste
busca cumplir el último gran reto de Leo
Messi es decir levantar la copa del
mundo que Argentina no gana desde el año
1986 Pero antes de eso deberá enfrentar
al potente equipo galo con el joven
mbappé y Antoine griezmann como
estandartes nuestra enviada especial a
Qatar Natalia Ruiz giraldo no se amplía
este domingo todos los sueños de Lionel
Messi bien podrían hacerse realidad en
caso de levantar la Copa Mundial esa
copa que le fue esquiva en la final de
Brasil en 2014 y Argentina que no ha
vuelto a ser campeona desde
1986 sin embargo las cosas han cambiado
bastante una selección argentina que a
lo largo de este mundial ha venido de
menos a más empezó perdiendo antes del
rival que parecía más fácil Arabia
Saudita para imponerse con brío tres
goles por cero a Croacia saben que
tendrán que tener cuidado ante la
delantera estelar que tiene Francia con
mbappé yogures
muchas preguntas también acerca de este
equipo francés que estaría siendo
afectado algunos de sus jugadores por un
virus gripal pero hoy estuvieron todos
entrenando Incluyendo a coman a connate
y también a vagan por supuesto los
argentinos pues ya saben que van a tener
que luchar bastante este partido Eso sí
dicen que no parten como favoritos en
realidad un estatus que de hecho les
conviene pero sea como sea de lo que
veremos en esta final este domingo en el
estadio del usai Lo cierto es que será
también el Duelo entre el fútbol
sudamericano y el fútbol europeo a
sabiendas que desde 2012 es decir hace
20 años todos los títulos mundiales se
los han llevado un equipo del viejo
continente
entre tanto ya se palpita en el ambiente
la tensión por esta final un encuentro
especial para los descendientes de los
cerca de 230.000 migrantes franceses que
fueron a la nación suramericana entre
los siglos 19 y 20 quebrarán el partido
con el corazón dividido Alba Santana nos
da los detalles
fue una migración muy importante entre
el siglo 19 y 20 en Argentina la de los
franceses pero en la final del mundial
de Argentina Francia los nietos y
bisnietos de esos migrantes se cantan a
por un bando ellos van con la luz del
este aunque algunos como Julieta riveros
nieta de franceses tienen sentimientos
encontrados si no estuvieras jugando
Argentina sería 100%
alentando a Francia pero Bueno
finalmente voy a como residuo y nací acá
voy a este alentar a Argentina al equipo
argentino
y es que aunque nunca fueron tan
numerosos como los italianos o los
españoles ni llevaron tantos
emprendimientos como los británicos
exportadores del fútbol los franceses si
consiguieron asentar su modelo cultural
algo que se puede ver en el modelo
educativo argentino o en la misma
arquitectura de Buenos Aires con una
herencia y relaciones bilaterales que
algunos esperan no se empañan por el
partido
[Música]
somos muy apreciados en todos los
sectores Esperamos que después de la
final eso continúe siendo igual con el
tiempo
otros como Franco argentino de primera
generación se enfrentan a un dilema aún
más grande residente de Buenos Aires
desde hace 20 años con mujeres e hijos
argentinos cree que los franceses no
entienden igual el fútbol
no se pueden comparar las culturas
futboleras no se puede los franceses
estamos a milenios de entender cómo se
vive aquí el fútbol
una historia y una afinidad compartidas
que se convertirán en rivalidad en el
campo de fútbol por el mayor título de
este deporte
continúan las manifestaciones en las
calles de Perú pidiendo la disolución
del gobierno y la liberación de Pedro
Castillo luego de intentar disolver el
congreso al menos 20 personas han muerto
en el marco de las protestas reprimidas
con fuerza por la policía este sábado
las fuerzas del orden intervinieron en
Lima en un local de la confederación
campesina del Perú del partido
izquierdista nuevo Perú y del partido
socialista entre tanto la presidenta
Dina boluarte pidió al congreso que
apruebe su propuesta de adelanto
electoral para diciembre de 2023
entonces señores congresistas no busquen
pretextos para no adelantar las
elecciones no se abstengan en el voto
voten directamente de cara al interés
del país
pararnos firmes para defender la
democracia
los firmes y decirles No a la violencia
mientras la crisis política y social se
acrecenta en el Perú miles de turistas
son Víctimas colaterales de la situación
en el país al no poder retornar a sus
lugares de origen Rafael Pérez nos
cuenta más
miles de turistas varados en Perú Esta
es otra Arista de la crisis política que
vive la nación suramericana Ah nosotros
ya llevamos aquí el lunes son hoy son
cinco días que estamos aquí con poca
información
de la situación actual del país por
regresar nosotros a la ciudad de cusco
como también otros visitantes también
exigieron una respuesta desde otros
puntos de la geografía peruana en un
hecho similar al menos 60 personas
encontraron retenidas en la ciudad de
chicaupe según los cajeros se
encontraban secuestrados queremos
informar al mundo entero de que
lastimosamente nos encontramos
secuestrados en el país de Perú muchos
de nosotros vinimos por turismo a
visitar este hermoso país nos
encontramos mal por esta situación y a
más de 24 horas es que nos encontramos
sin comer sin tomar agua sin servicios
básicos lastimosamente sin protección de
la policía el estado no nos ha dado una
respuesta al momento para poder lograr
un paso a nuestros países estamos
completamente cercados acá y obviamente
con la zozobra de ser agredidos
físicamente y es que a nivel nacional el
panorama no parece cambiar en medio de
un estado emergencia declarado por el
gobierno los manifestantes exigen la
libertad del expresidente Pedro castillo
y la renuncia del actual jefa de estado
Dina boluarte mientras ninguna de las
partes parece ceder en sus objetivos los
extranjeros retenidos en Perú continúan
reclamando retornar a sus lugares de
origen
la Organización Mundial de la Salud
señala que fumar tabaco es la principal
causa del cáncer de pulmón en el mundo
pero en Bolivia un estudio ha revelado
que la mayoría de los pacientes se
enfermaron por respirar aire contaminado
ya que no fumaban ni frecuentaban un
ambiente de fumadores Mary vaca nos da
detalles en el siguiente informe
Alejandro Marconi de 51 años Sufre de
cáncer de pulmón avanzado desde el año
pasado su día a día es luchar para
seguir viviendo en una ciudad con
índices altos de polución
Esperanza no hay acá en Sí en Bolivia no
no no hay los que estamos con enfermo
cáncer solamente luchamos para vivir un
poco más Aunque Alejandro fumaba
ocasionalmente El origen de su
enfermedad según los médicos podría ser
la contaminación ambiental el ambiente
que tenemos acá en La Paz está
contaminado entonces
con lo que estaba un poquito ya
delicado o algo puede ser uno de los
factores según ellos la contaminación
ambiental ha sido identificada como una
de las mayores causas del cáncer de
pulmón en Bolivia según un estudio de
2.160 casos realizado por los neumólogos
del instituto Nacional del tórax dejando
atrás al tabaquismo como la razón
principal tenemos por lo menos un 60% de
casos en gente que jamás ha fumado
tampoco tiene en su entorno ningún
fumador y que desarrolla cáncer de
pulmón la conclusión ha causado una
alerta porque el país ha vivido picos de
contaminación ambiental debido a las
quemas agrícolas el meteorólogo Luis
blacut ha advertido que en términos
proporcionales los incendios en Bolivia
son los peores de la región como han
mostrado los mapas de la NASA
contaminamos más que nuestros vecinos
como Brasil como Argentina esto es esto
es alarmante según los neumólogos las
consecuencias de respirar aire
contaminado y contraer cáncer no son
visibles de forma inmediata y pueden
darse en un plazo de cinco a diez años a
los bolivianos solo les queda volver a
los tapabocas cuando la polución Se
dispara hasta aquí este repaso
informativo sigan conectado esa France
24 y France 24.com
[Música]